(electronic beeping)
- Dr. Miller is back to speak about
adverse childhood
experiences and associations
with developmental disabilities.
Dr. Miller.
- Well, thank you.
That was a short break. (chuckles)
I will have to mention
that though I work for the California EPA,
that none of my comments today represent
the state of California in any way.
And as far as disclosures,
I do get funding for our
pediatric environmental
health specialty unit
from two federal agencies,
the ATSDR,
Agency for Toxic Substances
and Disease Registry
is part of the CDC now,
and the US EPA.
And I think this is the third time
in about six years
that I've been honored to be invited here.
These are objectives that I put out.
This is very kind of specific things.
But really what I'm here is
to introduce issues
about the environment
as might be relevant to people that are
involved in dealing with
various developmental
issues and disabilities.
And I think it's, if I
could get some interest,
then what you do with that as
a profession or a group of professions,
you know, that's for you people.
I don't really have
that particular answer.
So this is the third time around
in a few years.
I'd like to thank Lucy
for inviting me again.
So if I do it enough times,
one of these times I'll get it right.
(chuckles)
The perspective that I have,
and I think I want to introduce here,
is this ecologic framework for health.
So this is what I would think of
as truly integrative medicine.
So things happen that are important
from the molecular level,
the cellular level,
organ system, and the individual,
but the persons involved
are nested within their family,
their home, their community,
in society in general.
And those influences
also impact our health and interact with
chemical exposures that we might have.
And then these events happen over
the life course.
So from preconception
through old age,
and then even in some cases
there's evidence of
multi-generational impacts.
Just as there are in the social world.
So I think that we need to be considering
and thinking about these things
as a total...
unit.
So one of the first concepts
that I think's important
is critical windows of development.
So there are times when children
may be particularly susceptible,
and the kinds of things that might impact
their development include nutrition,
access to healthcare,
social stressors including
racism and other things.
I think you're all familiar with
the adverse developmental consequences
of early major stressors in the house.
But finances, chemical exposures,
educational support, et cetera.
These all are important and they interact.
I think that's the key.
So critical windows actually occur
throughout childhood
and there's windows of
vulnerability, okay?
Here's an example.
This is a stress example.
Now these, they took adult women
and they went back and got information
about their prenatal time period
when they were a fetus.
And they used some very simple measures
to look at major stressors,
ones that would not probably be
remembered incorrectly.
A divorce of your parents.
A death close in the family.
Refugee status.
Things like that.
And then they looked at these adult women
and measured a number of things
and they saw an increased
response to stress,
the hypothalamic pituitary access
was functioning differently.
Increased reaction to stress.
They had a biased toward
an allergic phenotype, Th2 phenotype.
They had increases in a bunch
of inflammatory markers.
These are adult women and the thing
they were looking at was prenatal stress.
So something that happens early
can affect you into adulthood.
Without showing anything before that.
These are bio markers
that we're looking at.
These aren't something
you're gonna see directly.
And this relates to an important
comp set called allostatis.
So you're all familiar with homeostasis,
how we regulate our
bodies physiologically.
Well, allostatis takes that idea and says,
well, the way we do that is by these
active mechanisms
and that those
are how we adapt.
And that's good,
but then think of it like
if your thyroid gland
may be ceasing to function well,
you're able to kick out from your brain
enough thyroid stimulating hormone
to flog your thyroid gland for awhile
and keep your thyroid
hormone levels normal.
But eventually you get a goiter
and eventually you may end up with
a not totally,
non-functioning thyroid gland.
So that's over the buildup
over time of these adaptive mechanisms
can result in harm.
That's called your allostatic load.
And that's mediated by neuroendocrine,
immune,
autonomic nervous system mechanisms.
These are all things that are important
and important for adaptation,
and it has a cost.
So the person who developed this idea,
largely Bruce McEwen, talks about it,
stress getting under your skin.
And the results can be metabolic,
cardiovascular, immune system,
and behavioral disregulation.
So neurodevelopmental things.
There's also windows of opportunity.
So those are vulnerability.
There are times when given the
positive environment,
you might be able to mitigate
some of these issues.
So one of the ways that led,
caused these problems, there are multiple,
but one of the ways is by impacting
the NMDA receptors in the hippocampus.
These are associated
with learning and memory.
These are glutamate receptors.
And lead and stress
are potent inhibitors of these.
So it's just to say that a chemical
and stress work,
not only did they have the same effect,
they work by the same mechanism
and they could be additive to each other.
Well, this is a beautiful experiment
where Tom Guilarte
took rodents and he exposed them
to lead at what's equivalent
to 10 micrograms per deciliter
in our children as neonates.
And then followed them to old age.
So as adults,
the lead exposure results in
decreased number
of NMDA receptors,
as well as decreases
in learning and memory.
Also brain-derived
neurotrophic factor.
So that alone is interesting,
but then he took and
divided the lead exposed
into two groups along with a control.
And one group he put in
an enriched environment.
So for a rodent that's more
other friends to play with in the cage
and a wheel and maybe a few other things,
a little bit more handling.
Those in the enriched environment
performed in their memory and learning
the same as the controls
that didn't get any lead.
And their NMDA receptor activity
was the same as controls.
So this indicates
there's an opportunity during
this developmental period
to at least mitigate some of
the negative effects.
So this talk really was designed around
and powered around the idea
of resilience in children,
and so that's part of it,
that we have opportunities
to these windows,
that if you let them go by
then things might be fixed.
So the brain-derived neurotrophic factor,
same kind of picture
as that NMDA receptor.
It's altered, lowered by depression
and these chemicals.
Methyl mercury and BPA.
These are common.
It's elevated by antidepressant
and by physical exercise.
And there's studies looking at combining
treatment for stroke victims
with both intensive physiotherapy
and behavioral therapy and then with
or without the antidepressant.
The antidepressant increases this ability
of the neurons to connect in a sense,
because that's the function of
brain-derived neurotrophic
factor is neurogenesis.
And so it helps to
increase the adaptation.
Why do I bring it up?
Well I think that the idea is
there are chemical
and social stressor factors
that both interact
and they're things in critical windows
when you might make some difference.
So how about with disabilities?
What do we know?
Well, not a lot.
The environmental health
world doesn't have,
I mean it has these kinds of things,
we have this exposure that might affect
attention deficit disorder incidents
or something like that.
But how about in
children or even adults
that have any kind of disability?
Is the exposure to methyl mercury
more or less of a concern?
Well, we don't really have much
information on that.
But here's one study that
looked at this testing
in North Carolina, I believe,
that they do an exit testing at
certain grade levels.
They make it really simple.
This bottom line here is
the impact of increasing your blood lead
from one to five micrograms per deciliter.
And these are
the lower scoring on the exit exams,
and these are the higher exams.
The impact of lead on those who were
already higher scoring is less than those
that were in the lower scoring group.
So I think that
to me that's an indication that
yes, you should be paying attention
to some of this stuff, you know.
This is potentially important.
So preconception, we know that people
are exposed preconception.
They can find
PCBs, polychlorinated
biphenyls, for example,
in the fluid
around the egg.
They...
we know that
sperm can be affected by exposure
to various chemicals.
In the work that I do
with childhood leukemia,
paternal smoking preconception
is associated with increased risk
of childhood leukemia.
So that indicates there's
some germ line alteration.
I think prenatal mother's health
and mother's chemical exposures
we're pretty familiar with.
I don't think I have to
say too much about that.
But certainly nutrition,
health, and medicines
are important.
But here's a study
that I think is pretty impactful.
They looked at chlorpyrifos,
which was the most used
insecticide in households up until
around 2004
when those (mumbles) were removed
partially because of these studies.
But is still used in agriculture.
And they measured core blood levels
of chlorpyrifos
and then they followed up these children
and then they have
three and seven years of follow up.
And so the more highly exposed,
still this is not high.
This is New York City residences.
These are not highly exposed people.
These are kind of average exposures.
There were delays in psychomotor
and mental developmental indexes.
Was related to
behavior checklist symptoms
of ADHD and PDD.
And there were declines in working memory
and full-scale IQ at seven years of age.
Well that alone is concerning, right?
But then they did this follow up
looking where they did
these functional MRIs,
very sophisticated MRI kind of exam,
and just looked at volume.
And there were these volumetric changes
in the surface of the brain
in a number of areas
in those with the higher exposures
compared to lesser exposure.
So remember what we
talked about with ADHD,
PDD, these behavioral things.
So here's the areas
that there was
its increase in surface matter
underlying white matter largely,
which according to the paper,
you might possibly consider that
to be like scarring for some cells.
But so you got the
posterior, middle temporal,
inferior post lateral gyri bilaterally.
What's that associated with?
Attention and receptive language.
Superior frontal gyrus, et cetera,
social cognition,
gyrus rectus,
reward, emotion, inhibitory control,
executive function.
So these areas are physically different
in the children with
these prenatal exposures
when they're older children.
So...
childhood has multiple windows,
things are developing at different times.
When you have rapid cell development,
that's a time period where a chemical
or potentially a social stressor
might be more impactful.
I think it's important,
I'm trying to stay on mostly
neurocognitive kinds of issues.
Air pollution,
now there's increasing number
of studies that show
that air pollutants are associated
with a variety of problems
including some,
now I don't think this is conclusive,
but some that would put
autism in a higher risk factor
with your air pollution,
including studies from
the MIND Institute.
But things have been
associated in studies.
Developmental delay,
inattention, ADHD,
anxiety,
actual volume changes in the brain
and neuro-inflammatory markers.
So a variety of things.
And for PAHs,
polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons,
those are things that any time
you burn things including fuel
in your cars or your diesel trucks,
you're creating these
and we're breathing them in.
There's not only an impact on
cognitive and behavioral outcomes,
but there's evidence of an interaction
between that
and maternal hardship, family hardship.
So...
in the environmental world
just like in the infectious disease world,
we want to think about prevention.
Actually let me go back one slide.
I want to point out TENDR,
the Targeting Environmental
Neuro-Developmental Risks.
This is a group
that has been convened
by Irva Hertz-Picciotto,
is a epidemiologist
at the MIND Institute at UC Davis.
And the Learning Disabilities Association
have been really involved.
There's clinical,
like many different nursing,
physician and other
health groups involved.
The researchers that are doing
a lot of this (mumbles).
They've put out some statements
and they're continuing to work on this.
Leslie and I have both been involved
and I have their website at the end.
I think it's important.
So their idea is we should be
trying to prevent these things.
Specifically we need to add to,
like the air pollution discussion,
well, this impacts
neurocognitive development.
This impacts things that
you are all concerned about.
Can we do something about it?
Well, there's not good studies.
There's one study in China,
but kind of marginal.
About neurocognitive outcomes
with decreasing exposure
to air pollutants.
But this is lung development.
And this is the Los Angeles Air Base.
And so you have particulate matter
and ozone, which decreased fairly
dramatically over the 20 years
from 1990 to 2010.
And the group that studies this
down in the LA area had three
separate cohorts that were growing up
during different time periods
of air pollution in Los Angeles.
And what you see is a decrease
over those time periods
so that those that grew up
with the cleaner air
had half of the number of kids
with decreased lung function.
Under 80% of predicted values.
Halved by that.
I think that it's likely
that that may be something
we will see with neurocognitive impacts
if we could,
it's more complicated to try to study.
So this is about resilience,
this is a model or
a communication tool
the Frameworks Institute developed
and it's just to say
okay, well, resilience has a lot
of different inputs into it.
And you can think of it like a scale.
If the scale balances to one side,
you may end up with a negative outcome
or a positive outcome.
So you can add together
these various factors.
Abuse, neglect, chemicals.
So that's what we add to it.
They talk about a lot of other things.
I'm adding chemicals
and you can see why.
I've just been talking about it.
You can have things that
support a positive outcome.
Opportunities for skilled development,
supportive relationships,
things your involved with your patients,
identifying early intervention.
We're talking about
early intervention here.
That can have an impact.
So even in the presence
of some negative factors,
yes, you can have a positive outcome.
It's also based on this fulcrum here.
So every person is a little different.
We come with different genetic makeup
and things can change where the fulcrum is
so that lesser or more amount of weight
on a side may drive it
to negative outcome
or to a positive outcome.
Well, think about if
your are exposed to lead
very early in life,
that moves your fulcrum.
Then you're more susceptible.
The same thing, you have
that enriched environment,
you might favor a positive outcome.
So again, back to what are these things?
Stressors that include finances,
built environment, chemicals,
education, social support.
A whole mish-mash of, it's everything.
So we have in our society
of individualism this idea that
positive outcomes are the result
of people bootstrapping themselves up.
All you gotta do is work hard enough.
Dale Carnegie.
You'll be a billionaire just like Trump.
Well, or that it's just a matter of
having enough will power.
Grit is a popular one now.
We're gonna teach our kids grit.
That's what's gonna make the difference.
We're gonna blame the victim.
Or the idea that resilience has no limit.
It doesn't matter how
many hardships you have.
If you work hard enough,
you're gonna take care of it.
The facts are that resilience is shaped
by these powerful factors including
social, physical, environmental factors.
And they're not easily overcome.
Yes, some people overcome the worst
of possible imaginable things.
And usually I think
you'll find that they have
some mitigating factors somewhere in that.
We can help the strength and resilience
by ensuring that we provide a healthy
environment both for
prenatally and in children.
The stuff you try to do every day.
So this comes to the background.
That's the background for
what is environmental justice?
Well, we had a slide in the morning
about this, a lot of things,
the Lanterman Act,
the coming out of the 1960s and '70s.
The environmental
movement came out of that.
And the environmental
movement then combined really
with the civil rights movement because
there were communities
that were highly impacted.
It turns out the same communities
that experienced
economic problems and racism
also are the communities
that are much more likely to be
next to a superfund site
or surrounded by freeways
or all these kinds of things.
So environmental justice was this idea
that everybody, regardless
of their background,
deserves fair treatment
and input and respect.
It started from an observation
that superfund sites
were both more prevalent in lower
socio-economic and communities of color
and also that they were waiting
far, far longer to get clean up.
So California EPA has this program called
CalEnviroScreen.
It's actually now on
the 3.0, just came out.
But it's an idea that
to combine all of these different factors.
So there's exposures to chemicals,
things like being near clean up sites,
sensitive populations,
and these socio-economic societal factors,
including things like
linguistic isolation.
So they map these things,
overlaid for the entire state.
And then they come up with, okay,
well, here these red communities
are in the top 20% of
exposures both societal, social,
and environmental.
And what we see is that
if you're a white child,
one in 14 are in one of those top 20%.
But if you're Latino or African American,
one in three of these children
in these communities.
So there's a dramatic difference.
And we see that that's actually
representative of the
United States in general.
The US EPA has a similar kind of program.
So just to say, well, just one thing.
Here's a study, I'm looking at schools.
If you live downwind,
close downwind to a school,
you have more traffic-related
air pollutants.
And then this study showed that
if your school was around these
traffic related air pollutants,
you had increased risk
of bronchitis and asthma.
Well, this is just looking at SES.
As SES,
well, this is,
this is a marker of school lunches.
So low SES.
As you go to lower to higher
traffic exposure,
you get more and more kids
that are low SES.
But beyond that,
this is going from low to high.
Traffic exposure and
then by ethnic groups.
And you can see for the Latinos,
the higher the traffic exposure,
the higher the percentage of Latinos.
Same thing for African American children.
And just the opposite for white children.
And this has been correlated with
academic performance.
So as you go,
if you go from low to high
air pollution levels,
academic performance decreases as well.
And they try to control for everything.
And trying to wrap up some of this,
this is from a study
of early intervention.
These are the 1960s, '70s,
early childhood education studies.
Kind of the precursors
or the beginnings of Head Start.
And those at this one
which was at Brookline, Massachusetts,
being in an enriched environment,
as this model's program was,
ended up in increasing
your high school graduation,
decreasing your
eventual involvement
with juvenile detention
and et cetera.
So this is your early childhood.
This is well demonstrated to
be cost effective.
And what were they studying?
I would say we don't exactly know.
This is SES.
Those are also the same kids
that were more likely to be
exposed to high lead levels
or any of these other things.
So are you possibly treating those?
There's been no intervention study
to date yet that looks at
the impact of
all this kinds of special
programs you might have
for children that are lead-exposed
to see does that alter the result.
So...
there are these critical windows.
Exposures can be chemical, physical,
social, historical.
Low income children,
communities of color
are disproportionately exposed
to both the social stressors
and to toxic environment.
And it's really important,
if you want to see the impact of things,
you gotta address more than
one of the multiple causes.
So then what does,
this is really trying to conclude,
what is somebody who's
a health professional
supposed to do?
I know this is overwhelming.
One, Leslie and I work for these PEHSU.
We not only do education,
but we help people work through questions.
Sometimes there's simple answers
and there's a lot of material
on our PEHSU website,
which is down here somewhere,
including fact sheets and
pesticides.
What would be one thing to come out with?
Integrated pest management.
That's trying to use less pesticide.
Doesn't say you wouldn't use any,
but it's approaches to
reduce pesticide use.
Lead, you might want to be screening.
Children with, it has been said
that anybody with
developmental disabilities
really should get a lead test.
Tobacco exposure.
You want to, that's pretty simple.
We all know about what to do.
Consumer products.
Here's a website, couple websites
with information,
one about cosmetics,
which are significant exposure to
endocrine disrupting
chemicals for young women
who are likely to be getting pregnant.
And then the last thing,
and you've got all this in your syllabus,
but the Story of Health.
That's a continuing education program
that we developed with
a bunch of partners.
You can get quite a few
credits for doing it.
It follows a family,
different members of the family
with different illnesses
through the multiple kinds of things
that might impact.
One, so there's a story about asthma,
a child with asthma.
There's a story about a child
with learning disabilities.
And a child with leukemia.
And we'll be releasing
in the next few months
one about infertility
and reproductive health.
And then other resources here.
I'll throw in National
Medical Legal Partnership.
If you're not aware of it,
that would be a good one because
a lot of environmental health things
turn out to be housing issues,
just like other things
we've heard about today.
Medical Legal Partnership.
There are over 200 of
'em around the country
where doctors and lawyers work together
to help address,
'cause we can't do everything.
Thank you.
(audience applause)